all right max dream
hello
max uh where are you from originally um
i'm from louisiana originally
what part southern um southern yeah so a
little town is about an hour from baton
rouge in an hour from lafayette but i
would work in lafayette because that was
like kind of the closest like smaller
city to me i love southern louisiana
yeah it's really nice beautiful
um and tell me about your childhood
growing up you had both your folks um so
i grew up basically with my granny like
my granny raised me primarily um my mom
and i we never really like got along i
did live with her for a few years though
um when i was in like fourth to
fourth to like ninth grade um but my
granny like really
raised me i would go see my granny for
the summers like go back to granny's
house for the summers what were your mom
and dad doing that
um well my mom she was like a exotic
dancer and stuff and um we just never
connected like we just never had much of
a relationship she was a little
we're just not the same type of person
and my dad he passed away whenever i was
like 10 so i'm sorry no that's okay
how would you describe your childhood
um i would say it was like
pretty pretty good and also like you
know there was some things that were bad
but i would say all in all it was pretty
pretty okay
no crazy abuse and all that kind of
stuff my mom was definitely like abusive
um not the type of like abuse that i
think like people see is abuse and that
was kind of like a mind
warp or whatever trying not to cuss
but like yeah it was definitely some
abuse going on um just like as far as
like mental abuse and she didn't really
hit me or nothing like that so it wasn't
anything like that but it was more just
like um kind of emotional excuse so yeah
how far did you go to school
um so i went up till
12th grade and then i dropped out so
like i dropped out
right before you get your diploma right
before then yeah so
yeah i was just like oh i'm too grown
i'm gonna get a job like yeah very
stupid but stay in school
so you're currently working at a brothel
yes outside of las vegas yes it's about
45 minutes
in a county outside of vegas where
prostitution is not legal in las vegas
but it's but it is legal just outside of
las vegas yeah in the smaller counties i
think it's a population thing so it's
like a population below i not entirely
sure how many people it has to be but it
has to be below a certain number of
people for you to have a brothel there
and then you can't open a new one it has
to be grandfathered in like with an
existing license is that right
and you worked there how long um so for
about three years actually my
anniversary of working there just passed
i was october 7th have you worked in
other brothels before i did yeah i used
to work at bunny ranch so oh up in near
reno yeah near uh i think it was carson
city it was like right outside of carson
city yeah i've been there before
so tell me about working as a
well first off how did you start doing
sex work
well i guess it was kind of like i
really didn't want to do sex work
honestly i was very embarrassed when i
got into it very ashamed and um i ended
up like having to be an exotic dancer to
pay my bills and i had like a big issue
with that because my mom was an exotic
dancer so i just thought like
she was mean because of that like i
thought that that was what made her like
this
unpleasant person and um
come to find out it wasn't because like
a lot of ladies who do that type of work
are very nice some of the nicest people
i've met but um you know i was real
ashamed and then i went strip at the
local strip club and everybody i knew
came see me naked like all my bosses and
like old friends and stuff so that was
interesting and um i just got like real
embarrassed and i kind of let it like
take me down a very like dark
path i got into drugs and everything and
so like at a certain point i was
embarrassed and i was like i gotta go
away like where people don't know me
and so i decided to
jump in my car and drive to northern
nevada to work at the bunny ranch um
before that though let me back up before
that i had like definitely
taken a couple clients outside of the
strip club because like every night
people would be like oh i'll give you a
thousand dollars come home with me and
if you didn't like word would get around
the club and when you weren't new
anymore it was like you wouldn't make
money because like it was just so
expected like no one said that they did
it but all the pretty girls did it like
everybody did it because that was just i
find it interesting how so many people
don't understand that strip clubs
to to my experience are just fronts for
i agree yeah i agree because there's
these back rooms and there's also a
phone number you can give out and you
meet a girl
i mean i've been propositioned so many
times at these clubs not that i go a lot
but when i
was looking for girls to
to photograph for my first book
you go to these places and they're
asking you if you want to have sex in
the back room it's true and it's not
about it i thought this was a strip flip
it's a whorehouse basically yeah if
you're not about it too like then you're
just like outcast like if you're a girl
who doesn't want to do it because i used
to be so stupid i used to be like no i
don't have sex for money like i'm sure
there are exceptions so somebody's going
to say i'm sure this club doesn't do
that yeah there's some clubs that are
that are run right or they try to run
them right i think but um yeah i don't
know it gets through the cracks like it
just becomes a thing people are always
offering these girls so much money it
kind of gets hard to turn down at a
certain point so
in your experience girls that do sex
work or work in the brothels or strip
clubs are
doing it
because they have kids and they need to
support them somehow and they don't have
a dad
a lot of the time yeah i mean i'm so
lucky that i don't have children because
i know some ladies who work in the
brothels and work in the sex industry
that got into it because of that because
we had kids to support or you know i
even know people that like you know uh
their mom or something was sick or they
had a family member that they needed to
take care of or you know just like weird
extenuating circumstances is that a word
i'm not sure but yeah weird
circumstances yeah i think there are
there are also a lot of girls that are
doing this on the high end that are
professionals or going to school or
becoming yeah
it's surprising some of the stories they
won't do interviews with me but but
they'll tell me like what they're doing
and it's like wow that's fascinating
because you would never suspect that
you're
you're your doctor your therapist would
be a
an escort no i so agree because like
there's a lawyer that used to work where
i work at at sheri's um she was a lawyer
and like she was like a hustler she'd be
like oh you 10 minutes rebook like you
know what i mean like and she was just
so like uh like a lawyer would be she
got paid for her time and she knew that
and um a lot of the girls that worked
there like the older ladies who have
been there while they're like real
estate moguls and doing all kinds of
stuff
i know a girl that was on america's got
talent that i met like a bunny ranch
actually and she was like one of the
girls that changed my whole perspective
about prostitution and like what it was
how did you do that um she just like was
the most ladylike most beautiful most
well put together lady you would never
think that this girl had sex yeah you
don't give off the vibe of a sexual i
mean like i'm gonna guess i like i like
to be like a kind of like a
different than what people expect and
she kind of taught me like you can be
different than what people expect i
guess
so yeah
thank you for that there's something for
everybody and not all guys just want to
i won't use the term but you know girl
who's just
yeah they're for one thing yeah and it's
like a lot of ladies i think get put in
a box like whenever they start doing
that type of work so they think they
have to be that like and you know i'm
sexual too like there's nothing wrong
with that either um but it's like you
can you can uh i don't know i think take
pride in it too so so today you're
working at the last three years you've
been working at
cherries yeah cherries and this is
outside of las vegas yeah um sherry's
ranch brothel yeah how many girls are
working there um i want to say there's
24 that we can have in the house max at
a time because it's like our licensing
yeah so it's like a pretty big brothel
it was smaller and then they added on at
some point and so like there's a part of
the floor that's like hollow it's where
the old brothel ended and like they just
built onto that but i want to say we
have like we probably have about 40
girls in rotation that like come in and
out some girls work more frequently than
others like i'm a regular
girl over there i work
like every other week or for sure like
every month at some point i work so yeah
and how i mean so the guys will come
there seven days a week or is it just a
weekend thing um yeah i know it's seven
days a week i used to not work the
weekends at all and i didn't like
working at nights either because it was
just kind of like a weird rowdy crowd
and i have confidence like i had
confidence so even during the day on a
tuesday
tuesdays were my best days when i first
started actually like during the day
like around like 11 a.m on a tuesday i
would sit in the bar and like drink red
wine and smoke cigarettes and read a
book and like what kind of guys come
into a brothel um nice guys at cherries
like i think it depends on the place
like but exactly because i see the
caliber of guys that work for that that
shop around on figueroa street i can't
imagine yeah or or here at skid row it's
even worse yeah no i can't imagine what
kind of guy would like yeah i really
can't even imagine what the guys are
like out here it's super dangerous too
yeah but they're complete gentlemen like
yeah so i think what you're doing is
probably the top of the food chain of
this kind of sex work i would say yeah
maybe this or like a very high end
escort yeah i'm like very lucky for that
it shouldn't be that way like i think we
should all be able to be treated with
respect like shouldn't be demonized or
like treated like less of a human
because you were in you know difficult
circumstances and had to choose to sell
your body but um yeah i know a lot of
ladies don't have working conditions
like me so like i would say we're
probably top one percent yeah and
it's a nice clean place and you're
tested yeah for everything all the time
right make me very aware of like my
sexual health because like i didn't even
like know about safe sex until i worked
at a brothel that sounds really bad but
it's like true my granny basically
raised me so nobody really gave me the
talk like sex was talked about around me
like my mom would talk about it and
stuff but it was never like i was never
talked to about it so it like created
this like fascination
so because you're working at this
higher end level of
of sex worker do you find what emotions
does this work bring up in you do you
get
depressed you get
angry do you get you know do you feel
disrespected sometimes or do you not i
can't really say that i ever do honestly
i have before like i did for sure as in
the strip clubs i did um at bunny ranch
sometimes um more often than not like i
would say that everybody's so nice like
honestly like i would say that the best
relationships i have are the ones that
i've made at sherry's like with the
clients and with the girls like it gave
me a better relationship with women and
with like men too because like they just
worship me treat me like princess how
much is a
a what do you call a session what do you
call it a party we call it partying a
party yeah like a party
how much is it to party with you well
it's um i like to say between like four
and five digits it could be more than
that um it could be less uh every lady
is different they make their own prices
but i'm not really at liberty to say
yeah specifics right but yeah
so it's pricey yeah so you so you
attract a higher end
clientele yes yeah like so that means
that means the
the danger element is is gone yeah
there's not i'd never feel in danger
over there like i do feel endangered
just like societally like that maybe
somebody could take out their anger on
you know me or the ladies i work with
just because we do the type of work we
do
you know there's like shootings and
stuff that happen that don't get talked
about um
not at the brothel um but like you know
it's a thing that we worry about
sometimes so um
that's about the only thing that i could
think of like i never fear a client
individually like they're all super nice
and if i get a weird vibe i just won't
see them because i can practice
discernment which i'm thankful for that
so you have the ability to say no if a
guy chooses you yeah like i think i
think the way it works the way i saw it
at uh the bunny ranch when i was there
is a guy would come in
and all the girls would line up in this
like circular room
and he would you know everyone would
introduce themselves and then he'd pick
one yeah and go off to the room and
that's that yeah it was a lineup house
over there do you mind if i drink my
water no sorry i'm both nervous
yes
you have the ability to say no if a guy
picks you yeah so like if you don't want
to see someone which i very seldom do as
long as someone's nice i'm like pretty
cool with them um but like people are
always like oh do you not see someone if
they like look a certain way and i'm
like nah i never don't see someone for
that but i won't see someone if they
have an ugly personality like once in a
blue moon somebody might walk in and be
like
not even disrespectful but less than
enthusiastic and it's like if you're
gonna be with me in that way i want you
to like
be happy about it i want you to be
excited for that because like i want you
to value it not feel ashamed you know
so what's the hardest part of this job
for you
um keeping up can uh like i love being
in contact with people the way that i am
but i would say just keeping up with
like the logistics of it people think
it's like a easy job but it's a lot of
communication it's a lot of like
emailing like i'm so not on top of it
lately um and just like um say i have
like something going on in my personal
life or like my mental health is kind of
like shaky um which is a great job for
that also because people are really
understanding but it's like i feel
guilty that maybe i can't like connect
with each and every person that reaches
out like any sex worker then
interviewing i'm
what i'm picking up is how difficult it
must be
to go
spend you know whatever 10 minutes or
half an hour an hour with
this guy who's
more aggressive and
maybe outgoing and then the other guys
are very quiet and all these different
personalities one after the other after
the other after the other and you have
to adapt for each different personality
and some of them can be wildly different
right yeah you do and it like it's true
like what you said about it making like
it makes you very adaptable yeah like um
it's but to me that's kind of cool
because it teaches you about like people
and how to interact you can take those
skills and do all kinds of different
jobs all kinds of things i also like my
um clients a lot of questions like you
know if they're lawyers i'll be like
well what is this like or what is it
like to do that or what's this law mean
like you know so i try to like get some
sort of like information out of it too
how is this doing this kind of work and
and interacting with all these kind of
men
um
change your personality
does it make you more outgoing or i
would say yeah because i was very shy
when i was younger i was like so shy
honestly and um at different points in
my life even not when i was just like a
kid but like there's points when i'll
just like be mentally ill and just
revert back into myself and it
definitely has brought me out of my
shell it gave me a lot of confidence
and what does your family think of this
well my granny she recently passed away
um so but she was actually very very
cool with it
she and i talked on the phone every
single day including while i was at the
brothel i'll be like oh granny my client
sent me all kind of gifts uh or like
granny is whole christmas like i call it
ho christmas when i get gifts just
because like i don't know i think it's
funny
and i like to laugh at myself and like
my life because it's hilarious um and
like um
she was always very cool with it like
she knew that i was safe and that i was
happy and she knew that it helped me
like really become sane and get my [ __ ]
together and like be able to comfortably
take care of myself i think when i
survived the pandemic on my own like she
knew that like i was okay and i think
that's why like maybe the way things
worked out that she passed away um is
because i was finally able to just like
be
self-sufficient and independent she knew
that i was like cared for there and so
she was fine with it
[Music]
one of the nice things about doing your
work at this level is you don't you
don't have pimps taking off
taking the money no the house does take
50 but to me that's like a small price
to pay for safety and um
yeah like safety and discretion if you
want it like i'm pretty open about what
i do but some ladies are not like they
want to go have other careers other
lives and stuff like you were saying and
so yeah no i think that it's kind of
worth it i think it's a little high
sometimes but um also like i don't know
it's like you can't really work safely
anywhere else and do this type of job so
yeah what's your favorite kind of job
favorite kind of job just in general
john trick oh guy
someone who likes to like talk to me uh
i like to talk to people like um kind of
like i guess get to know like why people
are the way they are but also like
someone who is just like interested in
talking to me like i like to talk to my
clients a lot so anybody like that
really do you think prostitution should
be legalized i do i do think it should
be legalized because i think that
there's so many women like in every
community and every place in the country
in the world that like have to sell
their body and it's like they're
demonized after that and it's like
they're outcasts and marginalized but
they weren't really welcome in society
anyways because of their circumstances
and i think it's really messed up i
think that like there would be a lot
less like
crimes committed there would be a lot
less murder there would be a lot less
human trafficking because it would like
expose it you know yeah um and i just
think that it would save people's lives
honestly oh i'm sure it would
definitely saved my life and a lot of
ladies like where i work would say that
too
when you were a young girl did you have
dreams of doing something with your life
yeah definitely um i had too many that
like that's the thing i could never
really put my finger on exactly what i
wanted to do
i used to tell my granny i wanted to
like be a politician or be like
president
um i was a makeup artist which i had
dreamed of being when i was a kid which
was cool but i did that when i was kind
of young and i wasn't like stable enough
in my life to like really
really i got embarrassed because like my
life circumstances were kind of uh you
know not the best
and um i was a little unstable like with
just you know my transportation things
like that and so like it was just hard
for me to like
keep myself together and at a certain
point i was like i'm not worthy to work
here and so i ended up just like leaving
and having a mental breakdown and was in
a mental hospital all that fun stuff so
do you think that maybe in some ways
you're following in your mom's footsteps
i didn't want to honestly i did
everything that i but you know she was a
stripper yeah you became a stripper and
that led to this she was at escort too
whenever i was young apparently because
my granny raised me so like my granny
told me that and i haven't apologized to
her because like that was kind of told
to me and then of course i'm a stupid
little kid and i was like shamed her
about it and i apologized to her i was
like i'm really sorry if i ever shamed
you for like you know telling your body
like there's nothing wrong with that
but um you know
we we we're different for different
reasons but yeah i know it's we're
almost twins for one and we're almost
like exactly the same person but it's
like we have a different heart like
that's what my granny would say is just
like
um i'm a lot more like uh
soft-hearted i guess
but yeah i know it's ironic because it
was everything that i like didn't want
to become but it's like
everybody that i ever had the audacity
to like judge i ended up like walking in
their shoes maybe as like a lesson or
something so do you feel any shame about
what you do no not at all not at all no
i feel like i give love and i feel like
there's nothing wrong with that and
these people give me love too so it's
like uh the only thing i feel ashamed
about is that i have better
situations to work in than like
every other woman who has to do this
type of work
but yeah no i i really don't i don't
feel like i do anything manipulative or
wrong in any way right
have you been in love before
i have i feel like i fall in love really
frequently and i fall in love like
really hard and fast so i can say like i
pretty much love everybody which is
weird but um and maybe that's the cliche
answer
but um i love my clients like i truly
like to say that because the caliber is
a little more yeah i love it there's
probably a chance that you actually
might yeah i do connect with somebody
right i do i connect with them i love
them i was really happy to go back to
the brothel after my granny died because
like the support that i don't have like
anywhere else in my life like i got at
the brothel um i got so many people
reach out to me and like be like max you
know i'm sorry to hear that no one else
reached out to me like from like say
like my hometown really they might have
like reached out to me on the low or
whatever but like no one really like
i don't know was there for me and the
way like the girls at the brothel were
and like um
the clients too like they're just so
sweet so i love them i really do i've
had a couple like boyfriends that i love
but it never really worked out
is it is it hard meeting guys outside of
this circle that you're in well i don't
really really really really because of
the work you do
um i mean i don't really try to but i
wouldn't say i wouldn't say it is i
would say that actually like my love
life improved once i started doing it
almost like i think there's a
fascination among men all kinds of men
with girls that do what you do yeah yeah
it is it's almost like a novelty but
then they may not want to admit it
but they're fascinated with the wild
girl that's doing this crazy thing
that's forbidden and wrong and yeah and
judged you know yeah personally but but
they're fascinated by it it is yeah it
is kind of fascinating i was fascinated
by it too like i was admitted
you're more desirable because of this
yeah no i agree with that because like
um yeah it's almost like we're like a
novelty but then it's like almost like
they expect me personally i can't speak
for everybody else but like me
personally they expect me to be wilder
than i am because i'm pretty vanilla i'm
actually like very boring
i dress like a boy a lot of the time i'm
like you know just
not really like a super sexual person
unless i'm like you know
being at work and being sexual i'm
actually celibate outside of the brothel
like i don't have sex at all yeah
and i can imagine that
one of these guys if he has the ability
to accept your
life
it could be a really beautiful
relationship yeah i have had like it's a
hard that's a hard ask it is a hard ask
but i don't know i don't think it is
though because like
if if i love somebody like for no reason
they give me nothing like they don't
give me money they're not making sure
that i'm supported the way my clients
are like my clients show me they love me
by like making sure that they invest in
my interest they buy me things so i can
learn things um
you know anything i want to learn like
i'll put it on my wish list or say i
want to do this or that like my clients
will get me that because they want to
see me develop my skills and like get
into things that i'm interested in and
like see me grow as a person your your
story about your clients is such a
drastic drastic extreme difference from
what i see with the girls on figueroa
it's so people who are picking up these
guys like creeps just trash yeah just
creeps that you wouldn't trust any
female to step in the car with yeah
cowardly cowardly i mean i hate to say
that like they're going to come for me
whatever they're unstable they're
they're dangerous they're they are
dangerous it's just like i'm horrified
and they're in normal like life like
that's the thing that freaks me out
about it is that they're like people
that are integrated in society like
these women are not allowed to be part
of society but these
depraved individuals are who would go
and hurt a woman or go and pay a woman
thirty dollars for a [ __ ] like how
sad you know what i mean but these are
the people that go home to their wives
um i don't know the people at the
brothel there at least at cherries and
specifically um they're so much
different they're so so much different
and it's like really crazy to see like
the range
that there is out there is this kind of
work for like can any girl do it or you
have to be a special kind of woman to do
it i mean
i think anyone could do it i didn't want
to do it i definitely wasn't the type of
girl that would have thought that i
would end up doing this i was real real
shy
um i didn't like even have sex with the
lights on before i started working in a
brothel yeah i was like real shy which
is stupid but yeah
now i'm like more comfortable with
myself and uh just people in general but
yeah no i think anyone could do it i was
in marching band i was a complete nerd
still am
so yeah i think anyone could do it if
they were in circumstances that kind of
like
required that because like i did kind of
have to get pushed into it like by like
just like life getting too much and the
money is good yeah the money is amazing
yeah so that would be hard for you to
just walk away from this right it would
be yeah i can't imagine like not having
home money getting it getting a job at
nordstrom's yeah it would be difficult i
did work at dillard's whenever i was
younger and i liked it but um when i
worked at mac but yeah um it would be
super difficult nowhere would ever like
compare like it would just wouldn't be
the same
and also i like it too so like that
would be
difficult to leave behind like my sense
of like family that i have over there
and rather than saying it
impedes your you know hurts your life in
some way it actually seems to boost your
self-esteem and make you feel good about
yourself and it has yeah it definitely
has i think it definitely depends on
like where you do it because
you mentioned mental health a little bit
earlier yeah i mean how has this job
impacted that i think it's significantly
improved it so like for instance where i
work at now when i started there i'd
shave my head and like gotten like kind
of kind of overweight like i had gained
a bunch of weight very rapidly because
my mental health was in a bad place and
so i just cut off all my hair
and um like i don't know i just kind of
like morphed into a person that i didn't
recognize
because i guess i was trying to like i
don't know what i was trying to do i
just wasn't really all the way sane i
couldn't really talk and i was just
trying to like um
maybe show people like to like back up
or like not
not like look at me like that you know
um because like you know there have been
situations when i wasn't respected like
i wasn't treated well
um you know even just in life not just
in the sex industry you know what i mean
um so yeah like i did that and then
working at sherry's like i remember i
couldn't look at anybody in the eyes
girls would like tell me hi and i'd just
think that they were being nice to me
and um
i don't know it ended up like really
making me feel like valued as a person
and like my boss really liked me and i
figured out i could trust her and trust
all the ladies i work with and it i
blossomed into like a different person
the same person but like a stronger
version of a person that i kind of like
recognized from when i was younger
um this is such a stigma to sex
especially in the united states that
people that do any kind of sex worker
they're gross they're judged harshly
yeah but i'm so i'm so vanilla like
compared to most people like um
i don't know i mean i know real estate
agents that are like super freaks and
almost no one i know that's a square or
whatever uses protection so like i know
i didn't ever before i worked in a broth
i didn't even know about that and drugs
alcohol or things for you currently um i
drink a little bit at work sometimes i
don't drink very much now especially
after the pandemic
because like i don't like hangovers but
i'll drink like they only give us six
shots of alcohol a day so it's six one
ounce shots and they have to be spaced
out an hour apart so like i might like
have a glass of wine and if i go in the
bungalow they'll give me two shots
because they encourage you to drink they
don't encourage you to drink a lot of
girls don't drink actually a lot of
girls don't drink at all but i i can
kind of meet her drinking it's never
been a problem for me drugs were a
problem for me when i was younger um for
like short periods though because i
would just go all the way crazy and um
it made me more assertive though it did
it did yeah i'm sure
do you have friends like friends outside
of this
um i would say that like
friends in the business like they're my
best friends they're really the only
friends i have and my neighbors i'm
friends with all my neighbors which is
really sweet and cute um but like it's
kind of weird because they all know i'm
a sex worker like they know i'm a
prostitute and um they're just like all
like there's a couple of them that even
were like oh i'mma tell my kid when
they're old enough that like you did
what you did and like that you were a
really nice lady like so that they
understand not to judge people
um so i have like friends like that but
most of the friends i've made are
through the brothel but they're like the
best friends i've ever had
never had better friends and because
it's legal
in vegas or
in parts of nevada
but even in vegas everyone knows that
this is something that's legal just
outside of town
that gives it a little more
respectability yeah
you don't have to hang your head and or
hide in shame you're you're like no i i
work a job just like you do yeah i tell
people like say a guy hits on me or
whatever i'll be like uh i'm a sex
worker and they're like excuse me like
what does that mean and um i'm like a
sex worker and they're like what excuse
me i don't like i don't understand i'm
like a prostitute like and then they're
just like like they can't believe that i
just like said it like that and then i'm
just like okay well have a nice day
you tell them where to go yeah i do i
give them so if a dude like asked me for
my number i give them my website i'm
like uh here let me write my website
down for you like
what have you learned about men or about
human beings in doing this kind of work
um
that like
i guess that
some people didn't get the love that
they need but like uh a lot of your
clients married a lot of them are yeah
um i learned a lot about human beings
and i learned a lot about like women
that like women
i don't know a lot of women are like
mean to each other but where i work
they're not like they're all friends
they genuinely like don't talk about
each other you've never seen like a
better working environment anywhere like
even restaurant industry any job and so
it's like i've learned the bunny ranch
as well i wouldn't say that no so i
would just say sherry's has a nice group
then yeah i think it's because dina um
our madame she's a lady and she runs it
and she just don't put up with no bs
like she don't put up with no drama she
doesn't want that she doesn't cultivate
an environment of like girls attack each
other and fight for my entertainment
like the way maybe some places would
what advice would you give to a young
lady who's thinking about doing
something like this um because what
you're doing is a very different it's
very different world than most of the
girls they interview i'd say if you're
going to do it
do it at a safe legal place if you can
get to one
make sure that you take care of your
sexual health
always always never compromise on that
and always keep yourself safe because
there are people out there that are
looking to hurt women who are in
vulnerable situations but also if you do
it do it all the way and don't be
ashamed of it because i think that
that's what keeps women in the industry
for too long is that they get ashamed of
it their life doesn't look how they
expected it to look or they feel like
they failed in some way and then they're
like i'm a prostitute so i'm going to do
all these bad things that
are cast onto me basically you know
all these things that i thought about
prostitution and then it just like it
kind of destroys them so just don't let
it be like that like if you're gonna do
it do it with pride like you um
be grateful that you can do it and like
you know have a plan save your money
that's what i would say do you have any
regrets in your life
yes you painted a pretty rosy picture of
your life it's not rosie it's not rosie
at all um but i don't have many regrets
though i have a couple but and and i
can't really say that their regrets
because honestly like i'm very blessed
for my life like i love my life i can't
believe i'm you're doing this interview
right now it's like kind of a weird
dream come true for me
but i can say that like maybe my regret
would be that i moved out of my granny's
house a little too early but i think
that every kid did that and i don't
really think it would have made that
much of a difference but it just like
kind of
once i moved out she got like sick
because she had had cancer whenever i
was like uh when i dropped out of high
school i think and um like
i just like moved out too early and i
should have stayed with her for at least
those next few months or whatever and so
i just trying to be too grown that was
like a regret of mine and being mean to
myself um treating everybody else with
so much kindness and then just being so
mean to myself and so hard on myself
like
and i'm just like why i should have
loved myself you should always be your
like own biggest fan and like your best
your best uh supporter and advocate and
i didn't treat myself like that so
that's my regret
is is female attracting this a commodity
oh i would say yes yes definitely
because the way you get treated um for
instance when i gained weight i was
treated like a completely different
person
my sex is like a survival skill for me
but not so much sex like attractiveness
is a survival skill for me but i think
it is kind of for everybody it's like
it's a woman's natural resource if she
doesn't have anything else you know
she has attractiveness and that's like
how you're picked is like oh like am i
going to marry a rich man and like hope
he'll take care of me well if i'm pretty
then i can get a dude that's like rich
and you know like that's so normal or i
can get a better job because i'm pretty
and like it it's a thing like pretty
privilege is a thing and so yeah the
more attractive you are the better
opportunities you have so yeah i
struggle with this sometimes i'll
try to think that i don't operate that
way yeah i'm above that everybody does
but but then
i try not to be like that i love people
i love all people yeah i mean i i'm
human yeah and there's certain things
that are more attractive to a man than
than others and that's just very true i
feel myself a lot more now than like
when i was bigger like i didn't feel i
didn't identify with that and i missed
being treated the way that i get treated
like as i look now like
you're happier
yeah with your physical appearance now i
am but i'm also happy with like my
mentality now too because like i was
pretty when i was younger i didn't feel
like i was and the mental health also
shows itself physically yeah for sure
you can you can look at you and you walk
in the door you can tell that this is
somebody who's happy and healthy yeah
well thanks
yeah i mean i'm not like my whole life
it's not rosy like i have problems just
like anybody else probably a lot of the
same problems that like you know these
women who work on figueroa have you know
to some extent or i have at some point
like that's how i even got into it
have you ever had any really special
clients who have really treated you
nicely um yeah honestly they're all
special like i mean i have
like the most romantic
loving um make me feel special
experiences i've ever had were with
clients i had this one client he was a
sci-fi author and he really helped me so
much um he would he didn't even want to
have sex either we'd go on like picnics
to the waterfall this was like up at
bunny ranch we do outdates and like he
ended up like helping me move my cats
across the country all kind of stuff and
um you know i had this one client he set
up this picnic in the park for me
guys are softies
yeah no they're they're sweet like
they're real sweet and um even like
people that don't spend a lot of money
they're really special they'll bring me
like um
gift cards or like you know little sweet
things like or they'll email me and be
like oh my god you like you made such a
difference in my life
um just like really appreciate me as a
person that helps me appreciate myself
but like as far as like big spenders
um i've had some like i've definitely
had some like amazingly generous people
but i really want to get my wife for a
week package like someone to come in and
book that and that's like when you just
book like the whole week and it is
expensive it's like a what would that be
like yes
yeah it'd be like six no no no it'd be
like five figures no no no it'd be six
figures yeah it'd be six figures so
someone you know and you live you're
their wife for a week basically yeah as
much as i can be and then you're out the
door yeah i mean i still talk to them i
keep in touch with everybody that i see
like they're my real friends what advice
would you give
to
a girl who doesn't have anything to do
with sex work just a regular girl
a square
just in general just in general in terms
of like self-esteem self-worth as a
female
attractiveness all these things we just
kind of talked about
um i would say
let me think about that for just a
second you seem to have learned a lot
about this this
not just the sex world but just also
just people existing as a woman in
today's society yeah i would say
you know um
be yourself and you know always make
sure that you don't do anything that's
like
out of character because i think that
that's the type of things that you have
to feel guilty for so it's like don't do
things that are like and when i say out
of character i mean like um
don't like say someone does you
something ugly don't go and like get
that dirt on your hands like you know
protect your heart like that's the one
thing that you have like be pure not as
in like oh i don't have sex i'm holier
than everybody else not like well
protect your sexual health but also like
really protect your heart because like
nobody can ever take that away from you
if you have a beautiful heart and that's
a million times more important than
having a beautiful exterior but i really
think that it shines whenever you do and
that is a thing that matters as well
maybe more than anything else that's
great
all right max dream thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you for
having me thank you very much
you